imagine you're the ceo of a large
japanese bank with hundreds of billions
of dollars under management
your bank has been a leading voice
within the japanese financial space for
decades but the future doesn't look so
bright the bank has been stagnating for
years and it's just a matter of time
until profits start to decline so you go
ahead and invest into every hype tech
company you can think of doordash uber
lemonade sofi supercell tick-tock tesla
netflix basically everything for a
couple of years you write up the
momentum of these growth stocks and your
bank starts to return to its former
glory but then one of your risky
investments wework jumps off a cliff and
you end up losing 8.9 billion dollars
to make things worse the pandemic rolls
around and it looks like all your risky
investments are about to get obliterated
a normal investor would probably just
not look at their portfolio until the
storm's over but you're not a normal
investor you're a giant bank
so you try to buy your way out of the
situation and pour gas on every stock
you own
and in just one year you go from posting
your biggest loss in 14 years to posting
the biggest profit in japanese history
in fact you make so much profit that you
become the sixth most profitable company
in the world pulling in 56.46 billion
dollars the second highest bank on the
list is goldman sachs and they only
pulled in roughly one-third of your
profit
so here's how softbank bought themselves
out of the pandemic
taking a look back the entire story of
softbank circles back to one man named
masayoshi-san
masayoshi was born on august 11th 1967
in kyushu japan growing up masayoshi had
a pretty modest childhood in fact it
wouldn't be a stretch to say that he was
poor
his grandfather had made a living as a
minor and his father was making a living
selling fish and pigs some reports even
suggest that masayoshi slept with the
pigs when he was young
so clearly masayoshi didn't have it easy
by any means and this motivated him to
work extremely hard and hustle as much
as possible when he was 16 for example
masayoshi looked up to a man named
denfujita who was the president of
mcdonald's japan then apparently had a
best-selling book that blew away
masayoshi and masayoshi was trying to
meet then ever since
masayoshi started off by repeatedly
calling his assistants in an effort to
get a meeting he says that he called
den's assistant 60 times over many
months and every time they told him that
they would ask then but they never got
back to him
so one day masayoshi decided to go to
mcdonald's headquarters in tokyo and ask
an assistant in person
and sure enough den would agree to meet
masayoshi right then and there for 15
minutes
then told masayoshi that if he was 16 he
would go to america to get his education
and then do something related to
computers
hearing this from his idol masayoshi
would instantly make the move he
contacted some relatives who lived in
south san francisco and arranged to move
in with them in san francisco masayoshi
attended saramont high school but
masayoshi had no intention of sticking
around masayoshi felt that he already
knew everything in the textbook and that
he didn't need to go to class
so he petitioned to just take all his
final exams and get his high school
diploma just three weeks later masa
yoshi aced all his exams and graduated
high school masayoshi would go on to
attend uc berkeley where he majored in
economics in college though academics
was no longer his primary focus
following den's advice masayoshi
attempted to create something in the
computer space he committed to coming up
with one new idea per day so that he
could iterate through a bunch of ideas
and pick the best one after several
months and over 250 ideas later
masayoshi settled on creating a
translation device that could translate
between japanese english and german he
would end up selling this technology to
sharp for 450 000 in 1978 but despite
making a substantial amount of cash
masayoshi didn't drop out of college he
eventually finished up his economics
degree in 1980 and returned to japan now
that he had money though instead of
getting a job masayoshi started softbank
in september of 1981
despite the name softbank the company
actually had nothing to do with the
banking or the financial industry the
company was originally a software
distribution company and masayoshi felt
that it was a bank for software hence
the name softbank was the first pc
software distributor in japan which gave
them a decent advantage but given the
small nature of the software market at
the time softbank needed other sources
of revenue so masayoshi expanded the
company into the magazine space in 1982.
softbank came out with two monthly
magazines called opc and omz these
magazines cover the manufacturing and
engineering sides of pcs as opposed to
the consumer side which was much more
common this unique coverage made these
magazines extremely popular and it
didn't take long for softbank to become
the largest pc magazine publisher in
japan in the meantime softbank
accidentally became more and more of an
investment advisor given that softbank
was publishing magazines that covered
the latest developments on the
engineering and manufacturing side of
pcs investors often based on investments
on these magazines
masayoshi decided to lean into this and
target american investors as well
in march of 1994 softbank expanded to
the u.s where they specialized in
identifying internet-related investment
opportunities
just a few months later softbank would
go half public through the otc markets
and end up raising 20 billion yen or
roughly 175 million dollars
softbank could use this cash to make
their own investments as opposed to just
recommending investments and with that
soft thing took their first steps into
becoming an actual bank
around the same time growth shifted away
from pc companies and into internet
companies masayoshi was well aware of
this trend and was determined to
capitalize on it in late 1995 he made an
investment into yahoo and over the next
year he would work with yahoo to launch
yahoo in japan
two years later softbank would go fully
public by debuting on the tokyo stock
exchange following the ipo softbank
quickly became a pure holding company
and they would make several investments
into internet companies but by far their
biggest investment of all time came in
2000 when they invested 20 million
dollars into alibaba ironically they
bought in at the peak of the dotcom
bubble but despite that the 20 million
investment has turned into wait for it
110 billion dollars and that's after the
50 crash alibaba experienced over the
past year alibaba has grown so large
that accounts for 47 of softbank's
entire assets so this was no doubt a
massive win for softbank but as the
dotgun bubble came to a close masayoshi
adopted a more conservative investing
style which led him to the
telecommunications industry
in july of 2004 they acquired japan
telecom company which got them into the
fixed line telecommunications business
two years later they bought vodafone
which got them into the mobile
communications business and in 2008 they
worked with apple to be the exclusive
provider of the iphone 3g in japan all
these endeavors allowed softbank to grow
through the early 2000s but the rate of
growth was nowhere near the 1980s and
90s
despite this masayoshi continued with
this more conservative style into the
2010s in july of 2013 softbank acquired
70 of sprint and they held on to this
purchase up until last year when they
sold it to t-mobile in the meantime
softbank's revenue and profit went from
slow growth to no growth some years were
better and some years were worse but for
the most part softbank profited between
4 and 8 billion dollars for five years
straight between 2012 and 2017.
masayoshi knew that something had to be
done so he started something called the
vision fund in 2017.
masayoshi looked back at what made
softbank successful in the first place
and the answer was clear outsized beds
in emerging industries the bulk of
softbank's exponential growth came from
pcs software and the internet so
masayoshi decided to return to the roots
of the company with the vision fund he
put 100 billion into vision fund and
focus on investing into all of the
upcoming tech companies including nvidia
flipkart arm gm slack one web all the
companies we mentioned at the beginning
and much much more
over the next few years softbank's
profits grew to 10 to 20 billion dollars
per year but then as we discussed at the
beginning we work happened softbank
quickly racked up billions of dollars
worth of losses in the first quarter of
2020 and we all know what came about in
march of 2020.
losses quickly compounded on each other
and it didn't take long for softbank to
be in the worst position they've ever
been in but luckily for soft fang they
had to ace up their sleeve which was
options trading
in summer of 2020 softbank went out and
bought 4 billion worth of options in
amazon netflix tesla microsoft alphabet
and 19 of the other biggest tech
companies in the world 4 billion alone
would be enough to move these stocks a
couple of percent but since it was
options their 4 billion purchase
actually translated to 50 billion worth
of stock i don't think i need to explain
how powerful this is
softbank was one of the leading factors
behind the tech rally in summer 2020
when the entire nasdaq rallied nearly 30
percent in three months to put that in
perspective it the market generally only
grows eight percent per year softbank
exited their options positions at the
end of 2020 but not before locking in
tens of billions of dollars worth of
profits
when it was revealed that softbank was
away about these massive purchases
investors in the sec were not happy the
sec launched an investigation into
softbank but we don't have a decision
yet in all likelihood though the sac is
unlikely to do anything to soft bank
because they probably didn't break any
laws
here's the thing it's not illegal to buy
4 billion worth of options
now if the sac is able to dig up some
sort of insider trading evidence or
evidence of a pump and dump then they
could find softbank but if all softbank
did was buy a crapload of options it's
not illegal and the sec can't do
anything about it even if the sec did
somehow find soft bank for hundreds of
millions or even a few billion it would
be nothing in comparison to the 50
billion they made so there's no doubt
that softbank came out on top
financially morally however it's
complicated do you guys think softbank
should be punished comment that down
below
also drop a like if you think that big
money has way too much power and of
course consider joining our discord
community to suggest future video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm hari and i'll see you guys on
the next one